so the other thing we want to talk about
of course is that you and i have been
trying to make the case i think i have
anyway that liberals need to stand up
for liberal principles this is what i
said on last week's show obviously i got
a lot of hate for it but all i'm saying
is that liberal principles like freedom
of speech freedom to practice any
religion you want without fear of
violence freedom to leave a religion
equality for women
equality for minorities including
homosexuals these are liberal principles
that liberals
applaud for
but then when you say in the muslim
world this is what's lacking
then they get upset yeah yeah well
liberals have really failed
on the topic of theocracy they'll
criticize white theocracy they'll
criticize christians
they'll
still get agitated over the abortion
clinic bombing that happened in 1984.
but when when
you want to talk about the treatment of
women and homosexuals and free thinkers
and and public intellectuals in the
muslim world
uh i would argue that liberals have
failed us and
uh the crucial point of confusion yeah
thank you thank god you're here yeah
well i mean the crucial point of
confusion is that that we have been sold
this meme of islamophobia where
every criticism of the doctrine of islam
gets conflated with bigotry toward
muslims as people right that is
intellectually ridiculous they even it
gets through the whole whole idea are
you the person who understands the
officially codified doctrine of islam
you're the interpreter so you can say
well this is what i think i'm actually
well educated on this topic i'm asking
you you're saying if i criticize the
you're saying that islamophobia is not a
real thing that if you're critical of
something well it's not a real thing
when we do it right
well well no it really is i'm not
denying that that certain people are
bigoted against muslims as people that's
right and that's a problem big of you
but
the
why is
it's gross it's racist it's not it's but
it's so it's so it's like saying that
you're a shifty jew you're not listening
absolutely not what we are saying you
guys are saying if you want to be
liberals believe in liberal principles
right freedom of speech like um you know
we are endowed by our forefathers of the
national that's right all men are
created no ben we have to be able to
criticize bad ideas and of course we do
no liberal doesn't happen okay but islam
but why is the motherload of bad ideas
jesus so we have it we have
ideas
you're painting is to some extent true
but it's hugely incomplete it is
certainly true that plenty of fanatics
and jihadis are muslim but the people
who are standing up to them malala uh
incredible muhammad ali
in iran in prison for nine years
speaking up for christians
a friend that i had in pakistan who was
shot this year uh rasheed rahman for
defending people accused of apostasies
more than a billion people who aren't
fanatical who don't punish women who
just want to go to school
let's get down to who has the right
answer here a billion people you say all
these billion people don't hold any of
those five or something don't hold these
pernicious beliefs no i wouldn't well
they don't that's just not true ben
that's just not true
can i can i just express how i think it
breaks down
the idea you haven't
you're trying to say that these few
people that's all the problem is these
few bad apples the idea that someone
should be killed if they leave
the that's horrible that shouldn't wait
wait wait you're saying that the idea
that someone should be killed if they
leave the islamic religion is just a few
bad apples
the people who would actually believe in
an act that you murder somebody if they
as islam is not the majority of muslims
at all okay is it let me let me break
this down
as you say we have 1.5 1.6 billion
muslims now second biggest religion in
the world the quarter well let me let me
unpack that let me unpack this for you
please do happen
just imagine some concentric circles
here you have at the center you have
jihadists these are people who wake up
in the morning wanting to kill apostates
wanting to to die trying they believe in
paradise horrible people and martyrdom
outside of them we have islamists these
are these are people who are just as
convinced of martyrdom and paradise and
and
wanting to to
voice their religion on the rest of
humanity but they want to work within
the system they're not going to blow
themselves up on a bus they want to
change governments they want to use
democracy against itself that that those
two circles
arguably are 20 percent of the muslim
world okay this is this is not what
you're interested in research a bunch of
poll results that we can talk about so
to give you one point of contact 78 of
british muslims think that the danish
cartoonist should have been prosecuted
78
so i'm being conservative when i roll
this back to 20
but outside of that circle you have
conservative muslims who
can can write can honestly look at isis
and say that that does not represent us
that we're horrified by that but they
hold views about human rights and about
women about homosexuals that are deeply
troubling so so these are not islamists
they're not jihadists but they but they
believe those abusers
they also keep women and homosexuals
immiserated in these cultures and we
have to empower the true reformers in
the muslim world to to change it
and lying about the the link between
doctrine and
behavior is not going to do that but the
great divide
the great divide is not between islam
and the rest it's rather between the
fundamentalists and the moderates in
each faith okay but we're misled to
think that the fundamentalists are the
fringe okay we have
jihadists islamists and conservatives
the strongest voices are coming from
those who are jihadists and extremists
and absolutely that represents a bigger
piece of the pie than we often think is
true there's no question okay so having
said that and if you even if that is
true statistically or otherwise the key
thing to recognize
that i don't think is part of the
argument but i think should be
is that there are voices that are often
time uh raised uh in opposition to these
jihadists yeah into these extreme acts
but guess what they don't get covered
they don't get exposed and they're not
given the same well
one green level of platform um that we
see the judgment one reason they don't
get exposed is because they're afraid to
speak out because that's the only it's
because it's the only religion that acts
like the mafia that will [ __ ] kill
you
if you say the wrong thing draw the
wrong picture or write the wrong book
there's a reason why ayan hersey ali
needs bodyguards 24 7. that element of
fear as well but you also have other
braver souls out there who do speak out
and who like who are risking their lives
you know like like the uh the muslim uh
clerics and on others in from australia
to to europe to the united states just
recently
publicly put their names on paper
declare declaring their opposition to
what isis and others are doing we need
so there are those voices but where was
the coverage where was where was that
story to sort of create a different
paper what is your solution what is
that's why we invaded we're knocking
we're not convincing anybody
i'm not specifically telling you that i
disagree with what you think
i know and we're obviously not convinced
if you don't understand my art you know
no it's not it's based on facts i can
show you a pew poll of egyptians they
are not outliers in the muslim world
that say like 90 of them believe death
is the appropriate response to leaving
the religion if 90 of brazilians thought
that death was the appropriate response
to leaving catholicism you would think
it was a bigger deal i would think it's
a big deal no matter what okay but
that's the character you don't but what
i would do is say it's all brazilians or
i wouldn't say well ted
god damn these gays they're all trying
to eat each other you know okay let me
just give you what you want there are
hundreds of millions of muslims who are
nominal muslims who don't take the faith
seriously who don't want to kill
apostates who are horrified by isis and
we need to defend these people prop them
up and let them report did you talk isis
couldn't fill a double a ballpark in
charleston west virginia and you were
making a career
not just isis
it's global it's a phenomenon of global
genocide i think that's the opposite
there is those things there is isis
there's global jihadist the question is
the degree to which you're willing to
say because i've witnessed this behavior
which we all object to on the part of
these people i'm willing to flatly
condemn those of you i don't know this
is
we're not making it up that there is
that in the muslim world it is
mainstream
belief but this is such a caricature of
indonesia of malaysia okay wait a minute
much of the world and this does have the
tinge a little bit of the way white
racists talk about african americans and
define blacks by what you're saying is
we shouldn't
make we shouldn't we shouldn't criticize
that's much of a minority the second's
biggest religion in the world exactly
but they're but you're treating them
like a minority i mean if filipinos were
capturing teenagers and sending them
into white slavery we would criticize
that we wouldn't say well the people who
were doing it not the philippines
you know what i mean well what if
the filipino kid lives down the street
from you would have nothing to do with
that so these are different things crazy
racial scenario
let's let's talk we mentioned isis let's
talk about that